god I wish I could pull that off you
look absolutely incredible you're
pulling it off no no no no look give me
that hat man if I say take it that looks
so cool on you and then I do it and it
looks a little bit like grass in there
because it's the proper size for me I
know this thing this is my Irish
yarmulke welcome welcome thank you so
much love having you on the program
a little you massive fan and it's so
nice having you here and you're always
so lovely to talk to and it's
interesting because I was think about
this today people all the time must
interact with you in the world and of
course they're talking to the actor
Giancarlo Esposito but there must be
some part of them it's like no I want to
I want to interact with Gus fring you
don't I'm saying I do know they and they
must want that they want that they want
that just like children want discipline
they want to tell me they want me to cut
their throat they want me to give them
the look you want to look yeah I want
the look yeah they want me to to
handcuff them you know oh that's it's
not getting sexy Oh didn't mean that way
okay well the only way I know it but you
have fans like you have fans that if
they know it's true
it must have fans who like people if I
take a selfie with them they want me to
do one of my signature goofy moves or
but that's what they want what do they
want you to do if you take a picture
with them oftentimes they don't want me
to smile at all ya want me to look at
them very coldly like I'm going to kill
them yeah they want me to tell them what
to do yeah yeah they want me to call
them employee of the month you are my
employee of the month you right yeah
yeah I like you yeah yeah
very nice people get very intimidated
when you just look at them yeah and you
take all of them in everybody ated when
you do that when you do that look right
into that camera right there and give
them that's when you people get
intimidated by that that's because
that's you and you have that ability my
version of that is this now think think
to yourself it just looks like I have
gas
think I am the boss doesn't work I did
my Andy right I just not in me yeah no
it's yeah no there's no intimidation
there one thing he's got bird bones
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there's a there recently you were taking
a selfie with someone and they wanted
you to look like you were holding a gun
on them it was a fan but she obviously
didn't have like a toy gun or anything
but she just used what was available she
did and what was it it was a banana that
was a banana so you took this picture
with you are so committed to one move
and she gets it and it's a banana
it's a Sears Portrait Studio I told her
I would peel her oh wow okay take it
easy okay okay you scare the crew in on
better call Saul I understand you can be
very intimidating on set when you're
when you're shooting better call Saul
yeah I go in as the character I don't
like to go to rehearse without being in
costume or wardrobe at the time and I
like to have everything you know at my
fingertips and I have an attitude
because that's who the character is I've
never you know try to go in and out of
it and many of the crew members are very
even though they've known me for many
years are very afraid of me when I'm in
that yellow shirt and those khaki pants
so I try to disarm them and tell them
hey just relax right I won't do anything
to you that you weren't expecting
see saying that is creepy to mice what
is wrong with me if I go up to my staff
and say relax I will do nothing to you
that's not expected they're gonna leave
they're just gonna leave cuz it sounds
creepy it sounds like a bad thing all
across the board I still contend that
people want to be guided through their
lives I contend that now people are
coming to a point where they want to
have more say yeah in the world that we
live in but still it's easier to be told
what to do and I have to tell you I'm
the person to tell you what